pression vous je vous demanderais qu'une
fois vous êtes qui y est vous on est les
avengers mec anosy
s'il s'empare de toutes les pierres
d'affinités
il pourra exterminer la moitié de la
planète pour planète massacre après
massacre mais pourra le faire bien
simplement jamais retrouver face à moi
si justement
oui mais jamais deux fois et je vais
avoir un nouveau marteau j'espère qu'il
fera
les problèmes
il va sûrement venir on fait venir en
capture
ah ah cette fois vous êtes tout foutu
légal
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous présente un de mes amis là-bas
jeu s'appelle steve voiture ingo
ensemble nous pourrons tué à dos
[Musique]
baguette
vous coller la honte devant des sorciers